Iowa State Fair over the weekend the big
stories were Trump and DeSantis but to
me the most interesting
stories centered around Vivek ramaswamy
and I have two clips of him I'll play
the first
for you and we're gonna we're gonna play
a game that I like to play which I just
made up this very moment called cringe
or relatable
so is the following clip cringe
or does it make Vivek relatable or both
that's possible too
let's watch this
everybody's joking now the clocks run
out time's up over plow snap back to
reality oh there goes gravity oh there
goes he's so mad but he won't give up
that easy
[Music]
lose yourself in the music uh
laughs
if you try to tell me that wasn't cringe
then you lose the game uh that's not
accept an acceptable answer I can't take
you seriously I mean it's definitely
it's cringe on steroids there's no way
around it
and it's not is some Vivic fans on
social media that's all we're uh we're
posting this video
and saying among other things that uh
that you know this is what you got to be
loose like this if you want to connect
with a younger audience yeah connect
with with the youth with this song that
song's 20 years old I hate to tell you
okay that's this is the oldies okay that
belongs on the Oldies Channel now
this is and I know if you're my age it's
a terrifying thing to think but I can
remember growing up in the 90s and
driving the car with my parents and they
put the oldie station on and the oldest
station that was that was saws in the
70s that's what counted as oldies so
that's an oldie now it's 20 years old
um
so it's not exactly connecting with the
youth
I don't think uh the youth are not
driving around in their cars listening
to Lose Yourself by Eminem from the year
2004 or whatever it was
and it it didn't seem to be connecting
much with the
um older folks in that crowd who are
just standing there to me looking kind
of confused like what is this guy doing
you're supposed to be giving us your tax
plan or something dude what is this
um now maybe you say
okay it's cringe yes no way around it
but it's also relatable and because
regular people do cringe things all the
time and we could relate to that
which okay sure
but it I mean if you walked out on stage
with a piece of broccoli stuck in his
teeth
accidentally that would make him
relatable in a certain way we've all
made that mistake before you got someone
stuck your teeth to go out in public
it's embarrassing we've all done that
but if you saw him doing that you would
still cringe and say what man that's
that's that's embarrassing that's gross
okay you wouldn't be more likely to vote
for him because he had something stuck
in his teeth he wouldn't go to the exit
polls after voting and say yeah you know
I was really looking for the candidate
who uh who had something stuck in his
teeth that was the quality I was most
looking forward to Canada so
relatability is not really the key when
it comes to presidents I actually
I don't want
the president to be relatable in that
sense okay we were just talking about
normal people and how we want our
leaders to understand normal people and
and understand their concerns and look
out for them and serve they're supposed
to be public servants which means they
should be serving the American people
many of whom are just normal people and
all that's true
but that doesn't mean that I want the
president to be just like some guy
down at the bar or someone who's
performing Bad karaoke at the bar like I
don't if you're at a bar and they're
doing karaoke
which I would I don't go to the bar and
karaoke nice but if but if I did I
wouldn't look it's like I want that
guy's president I wouldn't do that
I would really like to get back to a
point call me old-fashioned
that's fine I am
um
old soul in a new world and I would I
would really like to get back to a point
at some point soon where the president
is a leader
and someone who acts with more dignity
and self-composure than normal you know
um
I think that would be a very good thing
and that doesn't help in that regard so
I again I guess this makes me
old-fashioned but I look at that I'm
like no I don't need this from the
president I don't need oh he's loose
he's having fun
you need to see the president having fun
is that is that what you is that the
quality you want in the presidency you
know I just want a guy who knows how to
have fun
I'd give it I could give a crap less if
he knows how to have fun
that's not why we're hiring him
okay you're hiring him to do a specific
job
and it's got nothing to do with having
fun do you ever read the fine print that
appears when you start browsing an
incognito mode well it says that your
activity might still be visible to your
employer your school your internet
service provider how can they even call
it incognito in that case well it really
stop people from seeing the sites you
visit you need to do what I do and use
expressvpn think about all the times
that you've used Wi-Fi at a coffee shop
a hotel even at your parents house
without expressvp in every site you
visit could be logged by the Admin of
that Network that's still true even when
you're in incognito mode
your home internet provider can also see
and record your your browsing data in
the US they're legally allowed to sell
that data to advertisers expressvpn is
an app that encrypts all of your network
data and reroutes it through a network
of secure servers so your private online
activity stays just that private
expressvpn works on all your devices
it's super easy to use the app literally
has one button you tap it to connect and
your browsing activity is secure from
prying eyes so stop letting strangers
invade your Online private privacy visit
expressvpn.com
mattwallshow and get three extra months
free
expressvpn.com Matt walshow to learn
more and also let's just be real about
it okay can we just be real about this
you watch that video there I know if
you're a Vivek ramaswamy fan you watch
that you want to find some way to say oh
it's great
if Beto O'Rourke was doing that
you would never stop laughing about it
nor should you
if that was a video of Beto or Pete
bootage doing that you would you would
not be able to you would laugh about it
for the next three weeks
without without ceasing because that's
how embarrassing and funny it would be
in all the wrong ways
so let's have a little consistency hey
YouTube thanks for listening to the show
if you'd like access to my full show
with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there